- Ça fait longtemps que je me
suis dit : Ah, mais j'aimerat de
Montréal.
- La chasse à l'emploi est
commencée pour Soakto.
sur le Centre des Sciences de
Montréal, qui tient deux
journées de recrutement.
marketing, ça serait un nouveau
défi, j'ai jamais fait ça.
- Les offres que j'ai vues sur
le tableau sont vraiment
intéressantes.- 80 postes sont r
pour l'été.CYBÈLE ROBICHAUD, diu
Centre des Sciences
- On cherche des animateurs
des techniciens multimédias,
on cherche des agents de
billetterie.
- Le Centre des Sciences a
souffert de la pandémie.
cet été, une première en 2 ans.
- C'est clair que les employés
ont bougé et ont dû trouver
d'autres plans de travail.
Donc maintenant, c'est à n
faire la démonstration à quel
point c'est un bon plan de
travail, de venir nous rejoi
cet été.
FRANÇOIS CHEVRIER, dir. général
Événements Attraction Québec
- Et on  estivale de
la relance.
- Une trentaine d'entreprises
touristiques tiennent des
journées de recrutement, car
acants dans l'industrie.- Des gs
craintes en disant : "Oui, mais
c'est un secteur fragile."
qui a eu un coup de vagues.
Mais c'est secteur solide,
c'est un secteur plein de
potentiels, qui est en forte
croissance avant l n'y a pas d'.
- Mais force est de constater
que les ARLAND, v.ARLAND, v.ARL.
publiques Croisières AML
c'était l'employeur qui
choisissait un employé à travers
un bassin d'employés. Là, c'est
d'employd'employd'employd'emplon
choix.
- Et devant trop de postes à
tourner tourner tourner tournerà
l'étranger.
- C'est coûteux, c'est
un processus qui est très long,
parce qu'il y a des postes qui
ne se comblent plus ici.
répondu à l'appel du Zoo de
Granby, mais là aussi il faut
trouver plus de personnel.
SAMUEL GRENIER, vice-président
- On a été obligés d'embaucher
personnes parce qu'ils
veulent faire un peu moins
d'heures. Pas tout le temps duje
possibilité pour profiter deleu.
- Plus que jamais,
faire prfaire prfaire prfaire p.
De jeunes retraités ont aussiétt
été. Quoi qu'il en soit,La procn
sera une grande de relance. Ver,
Radio-Canada, Mon